[Music]
and human wave news submitted by born in
the USA over 40 people were injured at a
water park after a water wave
malfunction I saw wait for wave pool do
we show the video this one's crazy I
want to see the witne I want to see this
so I watched it multiple time forty-four
people injured people broke rib
oh [ __ ] but that's not important let's
watch this video you know how I love
natural disasters right watch this
shit's [ __ ] good in this where where
is this this is I will tell you this
yeah good that's so good - it's [ __ ]
like North Shore Hawaii like surf
competition noise honestly it's probably
from the other people pumping into that
or smashing into the coz if it was just
like you're in the ocean you wouldn't
hit any body on body body just slamming
into each other like that so randomly
there was just like an 8 foot wave that
just came out of nowhere there's
somebody at the wave pool was like that
it's just yeah ended up and we're going
home early this was in China this
happened after the tsunami pool
malfunction causing a sudden and massive
tidal wave it is called the tsunami I
thought the guy was wrong and living up
to his name and whoa no that's not why
that's not why it really so it
malfunction by there was a power cut
that damaged electronic equipment in the
tsunami pool control room which led to
the waves in the tsunami pool becoming
way too big and injuring people damn
another thing that I read was the guy
was [ __ ] drunk on the job and then he
was just [ __ ] [ __ ] off yeah well
that's what it's it says it here that
rumors say that a worker longingly can
operate the controls but that actually
isn't what happened but who the [ __ ]
okay it could be it could be a cover-up
who knows the crazy thing is the I
didn't know that there is even a [ __ ]
option for that tsunami wave to be that
crane and
suddenly - it's like I'm thinking
physics like physics wise like when you
make a poor way VIN the pooling you have
like build up the momentum right but
that [ __ ] just came out of nowhere and
you're gonna go this way yeah oh yeah
you have to give - like when it comes
out you jump with it and they supposed
to be like this like calming thing I
don't I don't like it because I just
could never time the jump right but I
that's scary
did you did you know there are people
out there who try to swim during like
crazy huge wave situations like surfers
and [ __ ] yeah like they would pay for
this kind of thing now with all those
bodies there you're gonna bump into each
other and you're just Chinese people if
it looks like all Hawaiians I feel like
they'd all be safe good arm so it's to
this Hawaiians our users have always
yeah
short wave breaks and yeah yeah like
they know they know their Beach but just
got locked up I don't know what it is
but I love like that's not even a
natural disaster but I love [ __ ] like
that it's so fun those natural disasters
so what you're saying you love that I
watch typhoons i watch like tsunamis
like I watch all oh my god they're like
so funny - I went down a hole on YouTube
where I was watching like the craziest
[ __ ] rollercoasters ever built that
had to be like like taken down because
they were too extreme
oh no the cameras were the key one oh
yeah dude exactly he was like disturbing
that earth is true but it was this water
park in New Jersey kind of where I grew
up called action Park and they they were
I was told that they had a waterslide
that had a loop-d-loop
and it decapitated somebody oh and I
don't know we need to verify this
Internet verify this well Kate got
decapitated recently on a water park and
they just sued in one I don't know if
those Action Party like how do you just
I mean that [ __ ] happens though but
there was a looky-loo point I mean the
mutant of pork accidents happen all the
time man yeah it's those hush money but
have a scary that's what always scares
me I'm like I'm the guy who gets on the
roller coaster and that's the last thing
you do right before the Hyksos when it
goes down right before it goes down I'm
like I'm about to die I'll be a news
headline right now
the ones that scare me are like you need
to strap it and then it's just a little
too losing their like holding on the
whole thing holding on like it'll do
anything yeah that's how I feel I just
go I hope I don't lose my wallet I
happen to be thinking about the whole
time I lost my wallet on a roller
coaster and I was getting off and my
friend saw in a bush and I don't even
know I lost it Wow blue and she's like
hey is this somebody's wallet oh [ __ ]
and it was like my driver's license is
just like oh that's the luckiest [ __ ]
that's why they call me the air con man
did you lose it but then you get it and
you didn't even know it just works I
know that's crazy that's why I never get
a role of course I'm scared of all these
now I ride the roller coaster look my
hands on top of my pockets cuz since
that happened yeah wait what's this
article about the title wait I might've
malfunction dude that's how [ __ ] good
my memory you heard that a drunk guy was
in the operating room yeah that's what I
heard oh and he's just like yeah [ __ ]
yeah
take it to 11 cuz that [ __ ] happens at
carnivals too you know there's like
drunk carnies that [ __ ] up rides and
stuff oh [ __ ] yeah yeah but I still love
rides man I can't yeah I get back on
yeah I'd be more scared I'd be more
scared of the piss in the water then the
actual [ __ ] malfunctioning I'm with you
oh yeah I would have you been to Del Mar
fair no in San Diego no is it like the
ocean fair like yeah where did this
one's like kind of more known in
California is like a big dope fair
I love Six Flags yeah I haven't gone in
so long so I mean but then when I did
recently go like I was in my 20s right
so when I was in high school me and my
friends would be able to go ride after
ride after ride and then sometimes we'll
go to the ones that are kind of not that
popular cuz the line you're gonna have a
like could just keep going over and over
and I try to do that like in my 20s with
my buddies I couldn't do it
I started getting headaches and [ __ ] and
I'm like damn what the [ __ ] dude I used
to love this [ __ ] just doing the simple
rants I know just trying to go on
rollercoasters back to back like we
would go on one and then we would just
[ __ ] run to the next one try to like
get in a shorter line or something you
know and since I turned 30 I don't even
wanna go a little closer really yeah I
was just a Disney I went on Space
Mountain and I went on the [ __ ]
California Adventure roller coaster goes
upside down and now I'm good what did it
feel that you're just like I'm too much
movement yeah I'm like because then my
friend was like only the Six Flags and
I'm like I'm not going to no six five
three my friends would get the map
before like the day of or whatever and
then like we would just like mark
everything like we're gonna go here we
plan your route yeah we would be [ __ ]
planet any we would try to like hit this
and then just freakin run to the next
one and then go over and over and over
dude I want on Six Flags I want to
Superman and twice and wrong one on
Tatsu all the [ __ ] and now that
terrifies the [ __ ] out of me tarek tops
is where you're like literally just
facing the ground all times strapped in
flying yet
never been to Six Flags I'm scared of
that [ __ ] probably never going roller
coaster when Batman came out that she
was a crazy ass line - dude that one's a
pretty crazy one constant loops you
remember well remember Colossus I mean
that's it's like the oldest one there
right but that was so funny because that
used to be the [ __ ]
alright Colossus is thought is it wooden
is it what it yes the wooden ones [ __ ]
you up yeah Joel because you feel
everything and they I think there's one
in the six fives in New Jersey they have
like a really fast one
it goes pretty fast and I went in the
middle it went at night so when you get
to the top there's no lights you can't
really see [ __ ] and you just go you get
your ass beat for whatever a minute and
a half I have terrible vision and I went
on that [ __ ] Harry Potter dragon ride
thing oh the dueling drag the Dueling
Dragons [ __ ] and that freaked me the
[ __ ] out cuz I can't see already I was
at night and I just couldn't see
anything so it was like I was like
riding into hell wow you know who got me
into rollercoasters is so [ __ ] funny
right so me my grandma my mom went to
Disneyland and my mom she doesn't want
to go on the rides and my grandma was
getting pissed at us cuz she's like you
guys are party poopers right so dime
like I don't like a party pooper huh how
was your grandma at this time
I don't know cuz I mean she just
recently died this here is just 98 KC's
old man Christ [ __ ] that's a lot she
math I don't know I don't know the math
I'm how many years apart is that she's
98 I'm 35 she was like 60 yeah so she's
60 and then so at that time she was like
getting pissed and I'm like I know [ __ ]
I'll [ __ ] go on the roller coaster
ten miles like you never been on one yet
do this [ __ ] and so we go on the whole
time I'm crying my [ __ ] eyes out and
then she's laughing at me and then she's
like are you ready for the next one and
I'm like I'm gonna do it imma [ __ ] I'm
not gonna let my grandma go alone didn't
I just like to like it whoa cuz after I
got over like the fear like just having
somebody there that wasn't scared and
also calling me out on my [ __ ] and call
me a little [ __ ] your mother it was my
grandma and then and then I felt like
well I got a protector because she can't
go on alone you know and then like just
being a kid with her and then having her
like just her having my back I I wasn't
scared no more yeah and then now it's
like after that I was like I can't wait
to go on rollercoasters
yeah it's weird it's crazy to be that
young and to know that your grandma's
that frail and old and [ __ ] cuz I don't
remember thinking that well they said
another time when I was like five or
something when me and my grandma would
go to the park I would walk on the side
where the cars were cuz I was like you
need to be protected by me and you're
five I'm like four or five and I'm like
walk on this side grandma are taller
than her remember this story but that's
what they would say is like yeah man
like you're always trying to protect her
and [ __ ] I'm like this little
[ __ ] gonna block a car oh yeah
give my grandma shrinks every time I see
her a little bit more like literally
like hurt like she's just smaller
because of her bones or maybe you get
tall are you getting taller I don't know
about that long time she's just her
bulges crunching together more yeah they
get pretty crunchy at least it's not
depressing yeah we're all the amount of
grandmothers now like the only thing I
did with my grandmother I used to watch
Three's Company with her because I used
to be able to work the VCR she's like
baby like put on put it on cuz that's a
new technology was at the time yeah when
I was not a VCR was it we had one of
those remotes to the track the tracker
remote so you can rewind mice meeting
the guy that's
that was like damn and then my dad was
he would don't touch it and then put it
in a plastic bag now my grandparents had
to watch wheel of fortune but they
called it wheel hey turn on phase and
[ __ ] wheel on Jesus yeah I'm not
going anywhere cuz wheels on it so
anyone ask if they go somewhere oh yeah
you could say would say like who's gonna
go pick up the pizza from Costco or
whatever and he's like yeah [ __ ]
wheels on go ahead and go pick it up oh
man I can't wait to like wear that old
and we say some crazy but we do say some
crazy [ __ ] now but I want to say some
crazy [ __ ] that's like outdated that's
gonna be fine dude well that's what will
happen to us is we'll say things that we
think are crazy but the kids think that
that's stupid yeah and then we're the
crazy old people I mean that's what's
happening now yeah I think so feel that
already you guys feel like you guys are
aging
it's know that I'm aging but I I find
that uh you know we're in this we're in
this stage right now of life of like
this [ __ ] that we saw his kids is being
remade now and you know like Ryan King
like everybody made you know like this
is added
well there was weird they had like it
was Lion King Aladdin men in black yeah
and their toy story and it was like
these are all movies that came out when
we were kids 95 all over they're seeing
it for the first time they're in yet a
new generation of kids were soon as good
as the original like I don't know what
you're talking about I just call my
grandkids a bunch of [ __ ] I just need
to pass that [ __ ] family heirloom
down is you need to be disrespectful to
be disrespectful
[Music]
you